we are the people of Iraq real
reconstruction aid one could call it
what one wants I'm not sure I'd call it
reparations but one we've you know we
destroyed their country we have failed
to provide them with the basic security
with the basic elements of human
security I think we need to withdraw
expeditiously as Barack Obama has talked
about and find a way with the
international community to bring
services elemental human services to the
people of Iraq and bring in the
countries in the region let's have a
diplomatic surge after this military
surge and that's what I think we owe the
people of Iraq sovereignty security with
Afghanistan I think we owe them a
similar dead which is the and the people
of Afghanistan have turned against the
NATO Western coalition for one failing
to provide reconstruction aid failing to
provide security allowing a central
government in Afghanistan to breed
corruption and of course the aerial
attacks air raids have killed too many
civilians and that in flames any
American sentiment we would do much
better to find a way to bring the
international community to Afghanistan
to find a way to negotiate the Karzai
government with the moderate elements of
the Taliban providing human rights
security for women and pouring money
into that country for targeted economic
development aid not for military
escalation which will ensnare the United
States as it did the British Empire the
Soviet empire in a quagmire so there are
many resources we can bring to bear
diplomatic economic development and
others instead of military escalation
it's a broader question no Brett because
i think the we have not done a good
enough job in rethinking what national
security means in europe there's a
lively debate about human security which
doesn't put military might at its core
sure military use is part of the toolbox
but there have to be other means of
engaging these two countries short of
continuing
these two wars which have done one
nothing for our security alienating
people in those countries turning them
against America in the West and not
providing for their citizens needs